PRESIDENT TRUMP TONIGHT AT
11:00 P.M. EASTERN ON "FOX NEWS
AT NIGHT" WITH SHANNON BREAM.
AT 20 PEOPLE OFFICIALLY VYING
FOR THE 2028 DEMOCRATIC
NOMINATION.
PRESIDENT TRUMP JUST TOLD
FOX NEWS BENNETT HAS NO CHANCE
TO WIN.
>> MICHAEL BENNET KNOWS ALL
ABOUT UPHILL BATTLES.
HE REPRESENTS THE ROCKIES.
NOW THE SENATOR WHO JUST BEAT
PROSTATE CANCER IS TRYING TO
BEAT 20 OTHER DEMOCRATS.
>> I CALLED MY MOM AND SAID TO
HER, SOMEBODY HAS TO BE 22, AND
THAT IS WHY I'M WRITING.
IT TURNS OUT I AM NOT, I'M 21.
SO I'VE ALREADY MADE A LITTLE
BIT OF PROGRESS.
>> HIS RACE TO QUALIFY FOR THE
DEBATE BEGINS TODAY.
HE STARTED TODAY ALMOST 2,000
DONORS SHORT OF THE 65,000 TO
GUARANTEE A SPOT.
THAT IS SOMETHING THAT WON'T BE
A PROBLEM FOR JOE BIDEN, RAISING
EYEBROWS ARGUING CHINA IS NOT A
PROBLEM.
>> THEY ARE NOT BAD FOLKS,
FOLKS.
BUT GUESS WHAT?
THEY ARE NOT IN COMPETITION FOR
US.
>> THAT IS NOT A GAFFE, BECAUSE
JOE BIDEN HAS BEEN SAYING IT FOR
YEARS.
>> I MOVED HERE FROM SCRANTON,
PENNSYLVANIA, THESE GUYS AREN'T
AN ECONOMIC PATCH ON OUR GENES.
THEY ARE NOT CLOSE!
>> BERNIE SANDERS A DISAGREES
TWEETING, IT'S WRONG TO PRETEND
CHINA ISN'T ONE OF OUR BIGGEST
ECONOMIC COMPETITORS.
>> CHINA IS GETTING STRONGER,
MILITARILY AND ECONOMICALLY.
>> CHINA IS ATTACKING US ON THE
INTERNET EVERY SINGLE DAY.
>> THEY ARE ALSO CALLING FOR
ATTORNEY GENERAL BARR TO RESIGN.
>> HE'S LOST THE CONFIDENCE OF
THE AMERICAN PEOPLE.
>> I THINK YOU ARE A HECK OF AN
HONORABLE GUY, I THINK IT'S AN
HONOR TO WORK WITH YOU.
>> FOR SOMETHING THAT HAPPENED
EIGHT YEARS AGO THIS WEEK, THE
SEAL SIX TEAM RAID THAT KILLED
BIN LADEN.
JOE BIDEN ADVISED OBAMA NOT TO
GO THAT NIGHT.
>> Mike: THANK YOU.
WE ARE HAPPY TO ANNOUNCE ANOTHER
FOX NEWS TOWN HALL FEATURING A
DEMOCRATIC CANDIDATE.
KIRSTEN GILLIBRAND WILL JOIN
CHRIS WALLACE IN IOWA SUNDAY,
JUNE 2ND, AT 7:00 P.M. EASTERN.
NEXT WEDNESDAY, BRET BAIER AND
MARTHA MacCALLUM WILL HOST
MINNESOTA SENATOR AMY KLOBUCHAR
FOR MILWAUKEE AT 6:30 EASTERN.